lubin's transformation into a terrifying
werewolf began with david thulis in a
partial mask to give the structure of
the wolf to be enhanced with cgi later
making their way through the blustering
storm just before grabbing the goblet of
fire in the middle of the maze wasn't as
dramatic for daniel radcliffe and robert
pattinson behind the scenes fred and
george left quite the impression with
that magical and literally explosive
exit every layer of effects just adds
more excitement to make a scene this
epic the crew began with a partially
built structure and managed to create a
full world this is one of the most
powerful and iconic images in the whole
film voldemort falling to pieces is one
of the most chilling images in the final
movie one that is satisfying for sure
after so long the only thing scarier
than snake nagini is fiery nagini the
effects used to bring the massive fire
beast to the screen were done expertly
especially seeing what the shot looked
like without cgi